ganz deutschland ächzt unter dem schnee
chaos ganz deutschland nein denn in
leipzig scheint der viele neuschnee
nicht alle zu stören im gegenteil so
sorgte etwa dieser spektakuläre auftritt
eines snowboarders für aufsehen im netz
ein video zeigt wie er sich von einem
geländewagen über den marktplatz ziehen
lässt einen tag später trifft in unserer
reporterin zum bild exklusiv interview
die idee dazu kam den erben snow server
der anonym bleiben möchte und seinen
kumpels relativ spontan damit trotzdem
lecker für um 6 gestellt und in der tat
sagt ordentlich nee ich habe mich
gefreut und dann sind wir losgefahren
und waren um 7 da und halb acht hatten
wir dann alles und hat heute die
snowboards bereitet sind und da durch
die innenstadt gefahren so lange bis die
polizei gesagt hat das einst so nicht in
ordnung
der snowboarder kam mit einer
polizeilichen verwarnung davon
obwohl diese aktion höchst illegal und
sicherlich auch gefährlich war
doch er sieht seine aktion etwas
lockerer als wir
7 uhr 30 dort waren da war noch kein
schneepflug durch die innenstadt
gefahren es war sozusagen jungfräulichen
schnee frischer powder so wirklich leer
und da hat man natürlich nie ein gefährt
wir sind zwar durch die fußgängerzone
gefahren
aber solange man dabei niemanden
gefährdet ist eine ordnungswidrigkeit
die mit 20 euro für das zu bestrafen ist
für die fahrer
meine meinung ist egal was die umstände
sind wir können sie mich ändern ich kann
es nicht ändern ich kann das beste draus
machen das war meine form für mich und
vielleicht für den einen oder anderen
ein bisschen spaß zu schenken
kein schlechtes gewissen also auf seiten
des windows servers zugegeben
spektakulär sind diese aufnahmen aber
eben auch gefährlich er der übermütige
border vom leipziger marktplatz meine
kollegin julia henke hat ihn getroffen
und ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet hallo
julia ja du hast in border getroffen wie
wirkte er auf dich naja also er will
jetzt natürlich als er wirkte auch wenn
man die bilder sieht wirkte er trotzdem
wirklich recht vernünftig also er hat zu
mir auch gesagt wir wollen damit mit
diesen bildern niemanden animieren das
irgendwie nach zu machen das war einfach
von von ihrer gruppe eben eine idee sie
werden sonst wenn jetzt nicht diese
corona maßnahmen der nach oberwiesenthal
gefahren und so dachten sie sich na ja
gut wir denn sonst den leipzigern
vielleicht ein lächeln ins gesicht und
dachten okay wir machen das früh am
morgen damit wir wirklich keinen
gefährden
aber natürlich wollen sie jetzt nicht
dass das jede woche machen und sie
möchten natürlich auch nicht dass es
irgendjemand nach abend also etwas
einsicht vom leipziger border dennoch
was sagt die polizei dazu also die
polizei meldete sich heute auch bei uns
auf unsere anfrage zurück und sagte
natürlich den ist das video auch
aufgefallen weil es ging hier in leipzig
wirklich gefühlt durch jede einzelne
whatsapp gruppe und natürlich sind sie
da auch dran aber man kann ihm wohl
höchstens eine ordnungswidrigkeit auf
rum und zwar wegen keiner keim
genehmigten fahren in der fußgängerzone
das ist das einzige was man eben ihm
vorhalten könnte
deswegen ist die polizei da schon
hinterher aber jetzt nicht ganz so
streng wie man vielleicht auf den ersten
blick vermuten wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren